الصحفي للرئيس الاوكراني فولو ميريزيلنسكي
ننوه فقط الى ان هذه هذا البث لهذا
المؤتمر ليس مباشرا
هذا
هذا الغزو ومن اجل تامين حريه اوروبا
واوكرانيا والعالم برمبته انا اشكر كل من
يتفهم هذه الاوضاع ويحاول مساعدتنا جميعا
في اوكرانيا اشكر الاتحاد الاوروبيه
على
تقديمها
مجموعه اضافيه بخمس مئه مليون يورو
وان مهمه الاتحاد
الاوروبي من اجل تدريب جنودنا
هي مهمه مفيده جدا وبالتالي سنستطيع تدريب
30 الف من جنودنا في هذه السنه ونحن نشكر
هذه البعثه
بتمويل هذه المهمه
واربعين مليون يورو ونحن نؤكد على عباره
السلام
وفي اطار هذه القمه حتى نبين في اطار هذه
الصيغه من اجل السلام وقمه السلام ان
الصيغه الاوكرانيه من اجل السلام هي عباره
عن خطه دقيقه من اجل
تعزيز الامن المشترك الذي تم تدميره من
قبل الغزو الروسي نحن ايضا تناولنا موضوع
تعزيز العقوبات ضد روسيا وتطلعاتنا فيما
يتعلق بالحزمه العاشره من العقوبات
ولقد تناولنا ايضا مساله
الصواريخ الروسيه
والعقوبات الفرديه
وامكانيه تعزيز
عمليات
المتابعه حتى لا يستطيع اي طرف الالتفاف
على تلك العقوبات وحتى ايضا لا يتم
تخفيف من وقع العقوبات الحاليه
رغم بعض
المضاربات التي تتم في بعض اعضائه الام
اتحادي الاوروبي لقد تحدثنا ايضا عن
عقوبات عادله من اجل اعاده الحق والعدل
لكل اولئك بحق كل اولئك الذين
اعانوا من الاعتداء الروسيه ومن اجل ايجاد
اليه
للحقوق من
شانها ان تقوم بمحاسبه كل اولئك الذين
ارتكبوا وشاركوا في هذا الاعتداء الروسي
وتحدثنا عن امكانيه
الاصول الروسيه حتى يتمكن من استخدامها في
اعاده اعمار اوكرانيا ولقد تحدثنا ايضا
وبطبيعه الحال عن التقدم المحرز في مجال
انضمامنا الى الاتحاد الاوروبي واريد ان
اشير ورغم هذه الحرب
الكبيره على اراضينا في ان 72%
من
التزاماتنا في اطار اتفاق الشراكه تم
تنفيذها ولقد التقينا باعضاء المفوضيه
الاوروبيه
وهناك الاعلان المشترك هذا الاعلان يتحدث
عن الشروع في المفاوضات من اجل الانضمام
في اقرب الاجال الممكنه ونحن تناولنا ايضا
هذه الجوانب مع المفوضيه الاوروبيه ومع
المجلس الاوروبي وهدفنا يتمثل بشروع في
هذه المفاوضات في هذه السنه هذا هو هدفنا
بل هو واجب علينا
وان قمه اليوم سمحت لنا بتحقيق هذا التقدم
فيما يتعلق
بالولوج الى السوق الداخليه الاوروبيه
وقمنا بوضع خطه من شان ان تسمح لاوكر ان
تصبح عضوا
بالفعل من ناحيه الواقع في مجال الطاقه
والرياضه والمال والجمارك والاضافه الى
مجالات اخرى اذا هذين اليومين هذا اليومين
بالاحرى من الاندماج على المسار الاوروبي
هنا في كييف اعطت اكلها والنتائج هي
ايجابيه وهذا سيسمح لنا
بالتقدم والتوجه الى الاتحاد الاوروبي
هناك مليار اليورو مخصص من اجل اعاده
الاعمار بصوره سريعه وهناك ايضا قرار فيما
يتعلق بالحزمه العاشره ضد المعتدي وهناك
الاعلان المشترك من اجل الشروع في مفاوضات
الانضمام في اقرب الاجال وهناك ايضا
النتائج
المرتبطه با
تنفيذ الصيغه الاوكرانيه من اجل السلام
وضروره تنظيم قمه من اجل السلام اشكركم
على دعمكم
شعبنا
ودولتنا ممتنه لكم المجد لاوكرانيا اعلان
لرئيس المجلس الاوروبي
اشكر لك سيد الرئيس على
الانضمام في هذه
القمه
وهالرتاله هناك واضحه رساله لكم ولشعب
الاوكراني ان الاتحاد الاوروبي نحن سندعم
الاتحاد الاوكرانيه بكل بكل الطرق نحن لا
نشعر باي
تهديد المقدمه من
الكرملين لاننا نحن والاوكرانيون عائله
واحده وانما مستقبل اوكرانيا هو في داخل
الاتحاد الاوروبي ان هذا الخيار واضح خيار
من اجل الحريه والديمقراطيه وان تكون
اوكرانيا جزءا من الاتحاد الاوروبي وهذا
قرار واضح ان مستقبلكم هو معنا داخل
اتحادنا الاوروبي مصيركم هو مصيرنا
مع الرئيس مع السيد جوزيف بوريل ومع شهر
وما ارسل نحن الى جانبكم عزيزي فلادمير
هذه لحظه مهمه انتم تشكلون رمزا لشعبكم
انتم تعبرون عن شجاعه الشعب الاوكرانيه
دعمنا كان الى جانبكم منذ البدايه وسنستمر
في هذا الدعم
لقد ساعدنا
حتى مستوى 60 مليار يورو على المستوى
العسكري والبنى التحتيه والمستشفيات
ونحن نريد ايضا ان نساعدكم من النواحي في
ساحه المعركه ايضا لقد قدمنا مساعده تقدر
ب 12 مليار يورو من ناحيه العسكريه وايضا
في مجال التدريب وقمنا بتدريب الكثير من
الجنود الاوكرانيين في هذه السنه
وقمنا ايضا
بتقديم مساعدات انسانيه من الان وحتى عام
وحتى اخر السنه وهناك الملايين
الاوكرانيين الذين هربوا من هذه الحرب
بحثنا عن الماوى والامن والامان واريد هنا
ان اعرب عن امتنان الصادق لكل البلدان
الذي قدمه الدعم لكل الاطفال والنساء
والاستقبالهم بكل ما يستطيعون في بلدانهم
هذا رمز للتضامن الاوروبي
نحن سنستمر في زياده الضغط على روسيا حتى
تضع حدا لهذه الحرب
الاتحاد الاوروبي قامت بفرض تسعه حزم من
العقوبات وعلينا القيام باكثر من ذلك
وسنقوم باكثر من ذلك هناك حزمه عاشره قيد
التحضير حتى نذهب الى ابعد مما وصلنا اليه
هذه العقوبات تعطي اكلها نحن استهدفنا
الاقتصاد الروسيه وبالتالي روسيا لن يكون
لديها تكنولوجيات متطوره
على روسيا ان
تكون مسؤوله عن الجرائم المرتكبه على
الاراضي الاوكرانيه ان اوكرانيا والاتحاد
الاوروبي سيستمراني في العمل معا حتى
يتم
فرض المسؤوليه على روسيا بشان تلك الجرائم
ونحن قمنا بانشاء مركز دولي
سيتناول هذا الموضوع موضوع الاعتداء
الروسي على اوكرانيا بالاضافه الى
مسؤوليتها
هذه المسؤوليه التي ارتكبتها وبالتالي على
روسيا ان تدفع تعويضاتها التي ارتكبتها
على اوكرانيا حتى تقوم ببناء ما قامت
روسيا بتدميره ان روسيا وان ان اوكرانيا
والاتحاد الاوروبي لدينا هدف مشترك الا
وهو حد لهذه الحرب
مع احترامي السياده الاوكرانيه
وعلينا ايضا ان نعمل مع الاوكرانيين على
مشروع للسلام مكون من عشره من عشره نقاط
في اطار قمه للسلام
في شارع حزيران الماضي البلدان الاوروبيه
اتخذوا قرارا مهما من اجل اوكرانيا
عندما نظرت في كل الجهود ان هذا التقدم
الذي احرزته اوكرانيا في اطار مكافحه
الفساد
كل هذه الاصلاحات تساعد الشعب الاوكراني
نحن ساعدنا وسنساعد الشعب الاوكراني في
هذا المسار حتى
تتمكن اوكرانيا من استخدام الاستفاده من
كل اتفاقات اتفاقات التبادل الحره
حتى تكون اوكرانيا جزءا من السوق
الاوروبيه ايضا
وهذه خطوه نحو الامام في هذا التقارب بين
اوكرانيا
واتحاد الاوروبي عزيزي الرئيس عزيزي ان
الاتحاد الاوروبي هنا الى جانبكم اليوم
هنا وغدا وطالما كان ذلك
لازما سنكون الى جانبكم من اجل اعاده بناء
اوكرانيا مزدهره
في اطار مسارنا المشترك الاوروبي
حد لاننا لا يمكن ان نحصل على اوروبا امنه
دون اوكرانيا امنه ان اوكرانيا هي الاتحاد
الاوروبي والاتحاد الاوروبي هي اوكرانيا
المجد الاوكرانيا وعاشت اوروبا
شكرا السيد الرئيس
شكرا على استضافتكم لهذه القمه هنا في كيف
اقول دائما بان اوكرانيا هي نموذج الالهام
في اوروبا واليوم لدي سبب اضافي يبرر هذا
القول
انا كنت مع رئيس الوزراء في مكتب للبريد
ولقد التقينا المواطنين عديدين جاءوا من
اجل تغيير مصابيح قديمه
لاستبداله بمصابيح كهربائيه افضل واقل
استهلاكا للطاقه هذا جزء من جانبنا الدولي
من اجل تقليص الطاقه وهذا جزء من
المنح التي تبلغ 15 مليون مصباح كهربائيه
نقدم 35 مليون مصباح كهربائيه
وهذا امر رائع ما ان قمنا بتقديم هذه
المنحه وفي الايام الاولى هناك 750 الف من
المواطنين الاوكرانيين توجهوا الى مكاتب
البريد حتى يبدلوا مصابيحهم القديمه
بمصابيح كهربائيه جديده واقل استهلاكا
للكهرباء هذا يساعدنا من العمل في اطار
الامن في مجال الطاقه هذا يعتبر رمزا لانه
وبعد هذه الزياره في ذلك المكتب مكتب
البريد
والهجمات كانت هناك هجمات جويه وبالتالي
قررنا الى اللجوء الى الملاجئ هذا يبين
يومياتكم وما تعانونه بصوره يوميه
هل هناك اي حاجه الى دليل
بان روسيا
تعاني من هزيمه استراتيجيه وبان اوكرانيا
هي صامده وتتحدث عن مستقبلها نحو الاتحاد
الاوروبي
بكوننا حاضرون هنا اليوم لهذه القمه
الرابعه والعشرين بين اوكرانيا والاتحاد
الاوروبي في خضمي هذه الحرب نحن هنا
نتحادث ونتناقش من اجل الحديث بشان
المستقبل الاوكراني هذا ربما يساوي كل
خطابات العالم ما قمتم به هذا امر خطير
ولكن هذا الواقع علينا الان ان نعمل في
الميدان في مجال الطاقه على سبيل المثال
وانا اقول 35 مليون مصباح كهربائي هو مثال
فقط
مليون مصباح سيتم توزيعها في كل انحاء
البلاد نحن
سنستطيع
بتقليص
كميات الكهرباء لتعادل
لنوفر ما يعادل ما ينتجه مفعل
نوويه وبالتالي نحن سنعمل في مجال تامين
الطاقه
مولدات الكهربائيه هي مهمه جدا في مثل هذه
الاحوال حتى
تستمر امدادات الكهرباء هذا امر مهم سنقدم
العديد من مولدات الكهرباء في هذا المجال
وايضا سنقدم مساعدات فيما يتعلق بالبناء
التحتيه حتى تصير كل الامور على ما يرام
في بدايه هذه
الحرب في الواقع كانت اوكرانيا هي التي
تصدر
الكهرباء الى اتحاد الاوروبي الان العكس
يحدث ان اوكرانيا بحاجه الى الكهرباء نحن
نقدم 2 جيجاوات من احتياجاتكم مع مساعده
كل مع مساعدتي كل بلدان الاعضاء في
الاوروبي نحن عبرنا عن هذا التضامن داخل
الاتحاد الاوروبي
وهذا الامر ايضا
يتعلق
بالتعويض وترميم كل اثار التدمير التي
تسببت بها القنابل القنابل بوتين
سنقوم
يعني هنا بترميم التحتيه الشوارع والمباني
وهذه اشغال واعمال يوميه وبالتالي نحن
بحاجه الى القيام بذلك بصوره سريعه هذا هو
هذه ربما اكبر عمليه
لعمليه البناء في هذا المجال
وانا سعيد بانه تم تقديم المليار الاول
اعاده البناء قمنا باجاء هذه العلاقات بين
الاتحاد الاوروبي سنبدا بالعمل مباشره حتى
نتمكن من القيام بذلك بصوره فوريه
وان المساعده الاقتصاديه مساعده الاقتصاد
هي هم جدا فيما يتعلق بدفع الاجور وايضا
ان يستمر الاقتصاد في العمل
حاليا الاتحاد الاوروبي قدم حوالي 50
مليار من خمسين مليار من اليوروهات من اجل
العمل
ونحن سنرى كيف يمكن ان نساعد
وندعم الاقتصاد الاوكراني في هذا المجال
هناك النجاح كبير
فيما يتعلق بممرات الامان وهي الطرق التي
تسمح بارسال السلعه والمنتجات الاوكرانيه
الى الاتحاد الاوروبي بصوره اسرع 25% من
اجمال الناتج المحليه تم نقلها من خلال
هذه الطرق طرق التضامن وهذا ما يمثل حوالي
عشرين مليار يورو ونحن سنستمر في هذا
البرنامج
ومن اجل اتاحه الوصول بصوره موسميه
للاسواق الاوروبيه كما كان الحال في السنه
الماضيه سيكون نفس الشيء في هذه السنه
ايضا
وبالتالي نحن
سنعمل حتى لا تدفع اوكرانيا ثمن هذا
البرنامج هناك الكثير تم تناوله في هذه
القمه كيف يمكن لروسيا ان تدفع اثمان
التدمير التي تسببت به راينا مع شركاء ما
هي افضل الخيارات في هذا المجال على
المذنبين ان يكونوا مسؤولين عن ذلك نحن
الان نقدم كل القرائم الادله المتعلقه
بجرائم الحرب هناك قضاه يعملون في هذا
المجال ينظرون ما هي المؤسسات
الضروريه في هذا المجال وهناك اراده
سياسيه حتى تدفع روسيا ثمن اعتدائها
وافعالها في اوكرانيا
ان الاقتصاد الروسي اصلا يدفع ثمنا باهظا
بسبب العقوبات هناك حزمه جديده من
العقوبات من سيتم تنفيذها من الان وحتى
الرابع والعشرين من شباط فبراير هذه
الحزمه هي مهمه جدا من العقوبات
وهي تركز على التكنولوجيات
التكنولوجيه اي سننظر بصوره معمقه فيما
يتعلق
المكونات التي
رايناها في المسيرات على سبيل المثال حتى
لا يحصل الروس باي شكل من اشكال على هذه
التكنولوجيات هناك ايضا المكونات مستخدمه
في المسيرات الايرانيه ايضا
وايضا
سنقوم ايضا بقطع
الطرق الاخرى وهذه
العقوبات تستهدف تلك الطرق ايضا
وبالتالي ان نركز على اوكرانيا
ان تصميمكم لا يصدق
وهناك الكثير من الاصلاحات
من اجل متابعه التوصيات الاوروبيه دون ان
تنسوا الحرب التي تخوضونها ضد المعتدي نحن
تحدثنا عن كل خطوه من الخطوات بالاضافه
الى الاصلاحات التي ينبغي القيام بها من
الاهميه بمكان ان يتم تنفيذ كل شيء وانا
اعرفه بانكم تعاقبون بكل شيء في هذا
الاطار
وجهودكم هي
واضحه
وستكون اذا ضمن تقريرا سيتم تقديمه من
الان وحتى فصل الخريف عندما استمع اليك
السيد الرئيس انا على ثقه على ثقه بانكم
ستستمرون في هذا الطريق لانكم تدركون ما
هو جيد بالنسبه لبلدكم
وهذه الجهود وهذه الاصلاحات ستسمح
لاوكرانيا ان تدخل في نظامنا الديمقراطي
الحر المجد لاوكرانيا
السودان
شكرا سيد زين سكين
لقد تحدثت البارحه عن العقوبات التي بدات
تتقلص
كيف يتم الالتفاف على العقوبات وهناك سؤال
بصبغه عسكريه
نظرا للخسائر في بخموت ما هي الاستراتيجيه
الان
هل ستقومون بنقل القوات من مكان الى اخر
او نشر قوات
اشكرك على هذا السؤال فيما يتعلق بسياسه
العقوبات
هذا هو اليوم الثاني
للمناقشات نحن
نتحدث عن هذا الموضوع ونحن نود
ان لا تستطيع
روسيا اعاده ترميمي
من منشاتها العسكريه
كم كانت كميه الصواريخ المنتجه في السابق
ونرى الان ما هي الوضع الان وذلك كله بفضل
العقوبات الاوروبيه والامريكيه والاخرى
وبالتالي من الاهميه بمكان الا يستطيع
الروس ان يلتفوا على هذه العقوبات هم
يحاولون القيامه بذلك وهم نكون بذلك
بفضل بلدان اخرى
ومن الاهميه بمكان ان يتم احترام هذه
العقوبات هناك منصه تقوم بجمع كل الادله
والقرائن ونحن
ننقلها وعلى كل العالم ان يكون يفهم ذلك
ويتحرك بناء على ذلك
واذا هذه البرامج برامج الصواريخ ونحن
قدمناها لاتحاد الاوروبي للرئيس شرمشيل
المفوضيا ارسل
وهناك ايضا المساعدات في مجال المسيرات
نحن نتابع يوما فيوم كل هذه الاجراءات
نحن عندما نرى بان هناك بلدان تقول بانها
شركه لنا ولكن من الناحيه الماليه هي
شريكه لروسيا في هذه الحرب هذا الامر
يصيبنا بخيبه امل ونحن ننقل الرساله في
الاتحاد الاوروبي وفي الاتحاد الامريكيه
حتى لا يكون هناك التفاف على هذه العقوبات
وبعد ذلك نحن نرى
المجالات المتعلقه بالطاقه النوويه ان
روسيا
احتلت
محطتنا نوويه في زابوريتا
وعلى جميع وحداتها
وسيده الرئيسه ارسل
قالت باننا ايضا نحن نتقارب مع الاتحاد
الاوروبيه على مجال الطاقه ونحن كنا في
الماضي مصدرين للطاقه قبل الاعتداء الروسي
ولكن وبعد لاهز ضربات على
البنى التحتيه في مجال الطاقه نحن الان
نستورد الطاقه ولحسن الحظ وشكر لله
انكم تساعدونا في مجال الطاقه
روسيا احتلت هذه الوحدات وحدات النوويه
لتوليد الطاقه الكهربائيه
والموظفون هم اوكرانيون وهم يعانون مما
يسميه بالاسترقاق المعاصر هؤلاء الموظفون
السلطات الروسيه تجبرهم تجبروا الموظفين
الاوكرانيين الاستمرار في العمل في تلك
المحطات وهم ياخذون كرهائن افراد عائلاتهم
وقاربهم حتى يستمروا في العمل
في محطه زابوريتشا ونحن لدينا ادله وقرائن
في هذا المجال هناك
ممثلين عن روزا توم الروزاتهم الذين
يذهبون الى ذلك الى ذلك تلك المحطه
النوويه وهذا نوع من الارهاب والاسترقاق
المعاصر ونحن ندد بذلك ونحن نريد ان نلفت
انتباه بعض الدول هذه الدول التي لا تريد
فرض عقوبات على روزات التوم وقاده روزيتون
هيئه الطاقه النوويه الروسيه
هؤلاء هؤلاء هذه البلدان عليهم ان يفهموا
بانه اذا تم اخذ الاطفال
رهائن الى روسيا هؤلاء لن يقبلوا ابدا
بهكذا حاله اريد ان يعرف الجميع في
الاتحاد الاوروبي وان يفهموا ينظر الى ذلك
وكل قاده الاتحاد الاوروبيه ان يتفهموا
ذلك وان يتخذوا القرارات المتعلقه بفرض
العقوبات السؤال الثاني فيما يتعلق بمخموت
لا احد هنا لن يستسلم احد في بخموت نحن
سنقاتل طالما سلزم الامر ذلك
ان محمود هي قلعه من قلاعنا ابطالنا هناك
الذين سقطوا
سقطوا في ساحه المعارك هناك هم ابطال
حقيقيون
ولو كانت لدينا اسلحه طويله المدى ولا تم
تسليمها لنا كنا سنستطيع ان نحرر محمود
ولكن ايضا ان نحرر دون باس الذي تم اراضي
اخرى تم احتلالها في عام 2014 نحن ممتنون
لكل البلدان التي تقف الى جانبنا في هذا
المجال السؤال التالي
سؤال من التلفزيون اوكرانيا الجديد
السيد الرئيس
انه اوكرانيا
اوفت بالتزاماتها
هل
هل اذا تم الوفاء بكل
بكل
التزامات هل الاتحاد الاوروبي سيوافق على
انضمام مع هذه الحرب ونرى بان هناك بلدان
اخرى
كهنغاريا لا تعمل بنفس اعمال الاتحاد
الاوروبيه
والان
هناك معلومات تصلنا
مفادها ولا سيما فيما يتعلق بما سيحدث
المستقبلا ولا سيما بعد مرور سنه على هذه
المعركه في الرابع والعشرين من شباط
فبراير
ان الجهود المقدم من اوكرانيا
المفوضيه قدمت تقريرا وفي نهايه العام
المزعج الاوروبي نحن سننظر في تقرير
المجلس ونتخذ قرارا بتوافق الاراء
بالاجماع عفوا بالاجماع وهناك اراده
حقيقيه من قبل اوكرانيا بالقيام بكل
الاصلاحات الضروريه
وهذه العمليه هي على مستوى الدول الاعضاء
تكون بالاجماعات من الان وحتى نهايه العام
المجلس الاوروبي سينظر في كل هذه النقاط
لتنتقل الى النقاط الاخرى هناك بحاجه
بطبيعه الحال الى اتفاق بالاجماع منذ سنه
نحن استطعنا ان نتخذ كل القرارات بالاجماع
من اجل مساعده اوكرانيا قدر استطاعتنا ومن
اجل فرد عقوباتنا على روسيا كانت هناك
تستعد
حزم من العقوبات فرضت على روسيا وهذا امر
مهم وهذا ما قلناها
وعلينا ايضا الان سنتناقش بشان الحزمه
العاشره
على مستوى الاتحاد الاوروبي والحلفاء
وستكون ايضا لقاءات على مستوى مجموعه
السبعه وسنقوم بكل جهودنا في هذا المجال
حتى يكون هناك اكبر تحالف ممكن من اجل
تفادي بطبيعه الحال الالتفاف في من قبل
روسيا على هذه العقوبات
ان موضوع
القبول لا ترتبط بجداول زمنيه جامده ولكن
الهدف هو تحسين الاوضاع في بلد ام مرشح
للانضمام وهذا جزء من المفاوضات والقبول
عندما ننظر الى تاريخ الاتحاد الاوروبي
هناك كانت فقط سته بلدان اوروبيه رئيسيه
نحن اليوم هذا العدد هو 27 بلدا هناك 21
تاريخ مختلف من المفاوضات للانضمام
والاتحاد الاوروبي وهذا يبين بانه ليس
هناك اجراءات هي نفسها بالنسبه لكل بلد
هذا البلد يتعلق بالبلد المرشح وكيف يتقدم
هذا البلد
وانا اقولها بصراحه انا مندهشه منبهره
اقول لكم احسنتم احسنتم السيد الرئيس فيما
يتعلق بالسرعه وبالدقه التي
تقومون بها من اجل التقدم بهذا الاصلاحات
وانتم مع العلم بانكم في حرب في نفس الوقت
قمنا بهذا الاصلاحات وتدافعون عن بلدكم في
هذه الحرب
وتقوم بكل ما هو ضروري والخطوات الضروريه
للتقدم وهذا وهذا انتم تستحقون ذلك
واحسنتم فيما يتعلق بالمراحل التاليه
سيكون هناك تقرير مقدم من الفوضيه
الاوروبيه الى الدول الاعضاء في الاتحاد
الاوروبي في الخريف القادم
وكل البلدان الذين يريدون ان يكونوا جزءا
من الاتحاد الاوروبي عليهم ان يقدموا
البيانات والمعطيات والاصلاحات
لكي نعرف ما هو التقدم المحرج وما هي
المستويات للتقدم ونحن كما قلت المفوضيه
دائما حاضر لتقديم مساعدتهم خبره في اطار
هذه العمليات المفوضيات رافقت دائما وابدا
البلدان التي ارادت في الماضي انضمام
الاتحاد الاوروبي ونحن سنعمل معا من اجل
تحقيق هذا التقرير في الخريف القادم
اريد ان اشكركم
اشكركم على هذا السؤال نحن فيما تعلو
بتحضاره بتحضيراتنا نحن نحضر انفسنا انا
والعسكريون
والاستخبارات نحن
نرى بان الضغط سيزداد في شرق البلاد روسيا
تريد ان تنتقم
بعد هزائمها وهي تريد ان تقوم بذلك في
الشرق وتريد ان تحتل الشرق وهدفنا هو الا
نتركها تفعل ذلك ولذلك علينا ان نعزز
قواتنا المسلحه بالاسلحه اللازمه ونحن
نعتقد بان الذين حظوظ كبيره في النجاح في
ذلك
ونحن نريد ايضا ان
ان نبقي في بالنا بان روسيا تريد ان تنتقم
ولا سيما بعد محاولتها الفاشله في الخريف
وقبل ذلك
وانتم تفهمون تماما ما هي المحاور المعنيه
وتعرفون ايضا
صمود صمود صمودا جنودنا هناك الذين هم
بحاجه صمود الى الاسلحه ونحن نقدم لدينا
ايضا المعلومات ليس فقط من قبل الشركاء
ولكن ايضا
من قبل مواطنينا
بفضل روحهم في بدايه هذه الحرب
كانت هناك حوافز ودوافع كبيره لدى جميع
المواطنين الكل كان يشعر بانهم صامدين
البعض في بعض المناطق قد بداوا
يرتاحون قليلا ربما هذا فيه شيء من شيء من
الضعف وانا اتوجه الى كل الصحافيين ولا
سيما صحفي الاوكرانيين
اتحدوا وتوحدوا من اجل
تعزيز هذه الروح
ورفع المعنويات حتى يفهم الجميع بان بلدنا
هو في حرب وعلينا جميعا
ان لا ننسى ابدا كيف بدات هذه الحرب
وهدفنا هو الا نسمح لروسيا ان تنتقم اذا
كان هذا المؤتمر الصحفي
المشترك بين رئيس
الاوكراني ورئيس مجلس الاوروبي ورئيسه
المفوضيه الاوروبيه